more very bad news for the failed former
president and and there will be other
bad news for him today as well
donald trump was deposed today
this is major major news and we already
have some reports as to what took place
trump to be deposed wednesday morning in
new york attorney general's probe of his
business this is something trump has
been seeking to avoid for a very long
time
donald trump's deposition for new york's
inquiry into the trump organization is
set for wednesday trump is set to be
grilled in manhattan by lawyers from new
york's attorney general leticia james
james has accused trump of misstating
property values to win tax breaks and
bank loans remember the way that that
works you have a property trump has a
building let's say it's worth two
million dollars when trump wants to use
that building as collateral for a loan
he says this is a three million dollar
building and then when trump wants to
have a lower tax liability in property
taxes on the building he says it's only
worth one million dollars that is
at the nexus at the core of this
investigation the article says donald
trump is scheduled to sit for his
long-delayed court-ordered deposition
wednesday morning we already have a
report about how it went donald trump
claiming that he refused to answer any
questions from the attorney general cnbc
report trump says he refused to answer
new york attorney general's questions in
probe of his business
trump made the announcement shortly
after he arrived at the offices of a.g
leticia james i once asked if you're
innocent why are you taking the fifth
amendment
now i know the answer to that question
remember trump used to say only the mob
takes the fifth why take the fifth if
you're innocent and now donald trump
availing himself of his fifth amendment
right which he reportedly invoked
numerous times today
uh donald trump also uh commenting on
truth social in advance of the hearing
quote in new york city tonight seeing
racist new york state attorney general
tomorrow for a continuation of the
greatest witch hunt in u.s history my
great company and myself are being
attacked from all sides banana republic
no sir i'm coming to you with tears in
my eyes and saying no sir
potentially accountability for anyone
because no one is above the law in the
united states is a good thing in fact
many so called banana republic sort of a
pejorative trump might sometimes call
them [ __ ] countries uh one of the
hallmarks of many of those countries is
there is not accountability for those in
the top echelons of power and privilege
if there is such accountability in the
united states that would be a good thing
not a bad thing so so much bad news for
donald trump after the break trump uh if
frenetically seeking a criminal defense
attorney
and donald trump's taxes are going to be
given to the house of representatives
could this be the worst 72-hour period
for trump
that we can remember
let me know your thoughts find me on
twitter at deepakman and we'll continue
after this short break
as many of you know i'm a busy person i
don't always have the exact correct
nutritional plan for my meals every
single day and that's why i also take a
multivitamin and a couple of supplements
but doing them all separately can be a
little bit time consuming which is why
athletic greens is just fantastic and
they're one of our sponsors i've been
using the athletic greens since last
year it just really simplifies nutrition
i just do a scoop of the ag-1 and i'm
getting 75 high quality vitamins and
minerals and my probiotics and it's all
from whole food sources i drink it in
the morning i know i'm good i don't have
to be messing around with different
pills and supplements or whatever or
spend time planning it when what time of
day do i need to take each one i just
get it all with one scoop you can put it
in a smoothie you can drink it straight
it tastes great and then i'm just good
for the day it supports gut health and
i'm getting everything that i need and
i'm looking for athletic greens is
giving my audience a free one-year
supply of vitamin d plus five free
travel packs when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below